David good morning take me back to
monday with dez bryant what was supposed
to happen in what did or didn't happen
well as brian suffered a knee injury and
sunday night's game against chicago came
back and played and actually scored a
touchdown late in the game on a slant
play ran over to bears defenders to get
in but clearly it hurt us me now the
players are off on Monday in Dallas but
players who were injured or required to
come in for treatment Dez Bryant didn't
show up on Monday Tuesday is when they
reconvene for a conditioning session and
team meetings Dez Bryant was not at the
team meetings on tuesday since he wasn't
there on Monday they had scheduled an
MRI for him on Tuesday but he showed up
too late at the facility to had the MRI
taken so the Cowboys go into Wednesday
without an MRI for a final diagnosis on
exactly what it is is wrong with him
head coach Jason Garrett is telling the
media that they're still in the process
of evaluating the knee he refuses to say
whether or not an MRI has been taken or
where they are in the process he does
they do get the results yesterday
afternoon afternoon wednesday afternoon
and it shows that he has a hairline
fracture of the tibial plateau and
that's where the tibia connects with the
knee my medical degree tells me that and
also talking to others that since i
don't have a medical degree so and it's
on the lateral side so that is something
that while they had not ruled him out
for Sunday's game in san francisco it is
highly unlikely he'll be able to play
sunday could be out two to three weeks
and the bottom line on all this is
because he did not show up for team
meetings and an MRI he has been fined by
the team okay the national perspective
it feels like is the blame is being
placed on Dez Bryant for not showing up
missing in action is that fair to blame
Dez Bryant in this
oh I think yeah I think a player has a
responsibility when injured knowing what
the protocol is for a particular team
when they are trying to ascertain what
the injury is I think he has an
obligation not only to himself but his
teammates to be as diligent and take
that as seriously as possible and gather
all the information that you can so you
can be so one you can address the injury
as quickly and as swiftly as possible as
far as what the rehab is needed and to
to allow your team strategically to
prepare for the next game yeah I don't
understand the whatever the motivation
is for dez bryant or lack of motivation
if you have an injury find out what it
is why is he being coy or deceptive with
this well that's what's perplexing about
it and all I can tell you is where he
wasn't I don't know where he was on
Monday and Tuesday he was we did see him
briefly at the facility yesterday he he
was in good spirits he was moving he was
moving with a noticeable limp but
appeared to be in good spirits on his
way to the weight room someone shouted
bullets are you know are you going to
play Sunday and he said I might that is
that is all the contact we had with them
so at this stage des brian hasn't really
spoken publicly to address why he wasn't
there monday or tuesday to have this MRI
done more quickly and why he went and
also again don't want to minimize why he
wasn't there for team meetings on on
tuesday when everyone else was how is
fam around with the Cowboys I'm sorry
how is morale with the cowboy fence Oh
with the fans very high right now
because they're seeing something they
haven't seen in a while they're seeing a
young quarterback not only win games in
the present but give them hope for the
future once Tony Romo no longer plays so
I think there and the expectations were
not that high going in based off of
coming off a four and 12 season and the
fact that that Prescott was viewed as a
developmental
I who really no one anticipated with
step on the field this year especially
the Cowboys I mean when when training
camp started this guy was the number
three quarterback now he's been as close
to flawless as you can be to start an
NFL career so with him in Ezekiel
Elliott I think Cowboys fans are pretty
excited and are watching something a
newness unfold that they haven't seen in
a while so I think the excitement is
really ramped up here and it's pretty
high I don't know it will be interesting
to see if this tamp down on it at all
Dez Bryant no came into this league with
some issues as far as whether how
disciplined he was questions about his
punctuality and showing up for meetings
he's made great strides in at that area
what happened this week was clearly a
step back is it a step back in a bump in
the road or is it a precursor of more to
come would be the question and I think
at this stage everyone is is a willing
to acknowledge it is a poor lapse of
judgment but not indicative of a larger
trend I'll leave you with this david is
there scenario where dak Prescott can
win this job outright I think that is
but over time yes if you're talking
about in the time frame of when Tony
Romo was cleared medically to return yes
I think that would be difficult I would
be surprised if Tony Romo doesn't go
back in there now that being said I
think that that Prescott in his play can
elongate how long Tony Romo was out and
then being cautious with his return but
I still think the way this would play
out over time as Tony Romo would come
back and he would have to play at a high
level and also show he can stay on the
field in order to retain the job but I
do believe that Tony Romo will have the
job when he comes back yeah great stuff
David thanks for joining us and we
appreciate it oh thank you so much
that's David more Dallas Morning News
cowboys reporter the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience
you